here now with more constitutional lawyer
scholar fox news contributor uh jonathan
turley jonathan let's first start before
we get into the warren itself and
and the history of the fbi and the doj
with donald trump i want to ask you
about the president's claim that
this has all been declassified anyway
your thoughts on oh that's that's a big
development that john solomon brought up
tonight
well it's a major question that has to
be addressed if there's going to be any
serious discussion of
of a criminal charge
the inclusion of the espionage act uh in
the warrant uh was notable because
that's the same
basis upon which hillary clinton was
investigated for her own controversy now
what was notable about that is that the
justice department at the time
said that they've never had faith in a
gross negligence
basis for using that statute and it was
on that basis that
they said that they had declined a
charge in the case
so the question here is whether the fbi
believes it has not gross negligence but
an intentional act by the former
president and that goes to this defense
now there's a lot that we have to learn
you know if if he was declassifying
material as we've been told in the final
days of his administration
uh there is obviously a ripe opportunity
for mistakes to be made by him by his
staff
by others
usually when you declassify a document
the markings are actually scratched out
there's a line drawn through them so
there's physical changes on this on the
face of these documents whether that
actually occurred or whether actual
declassification occurred may be at the
heart of this controversy but that's a
very muddled record because
the president has inherent
declassification authority there are
regulations we've never really had to
litigate that question as to what is
necessary for declassification to be
viewed as a legal finality or certainty
but also whether the president could
have had a good faith reason to believe
that there was declassification all of
that we're going to have to
work out if the department of justice
goes forward that we have the the issue
of the timeline the national archives
and record administration their letter
of thanks for all the cooperation of of
the trump team at mar-a-lago from
february of this year uh and then i
think a very important date is june 3rd
because you had the fbi and doj
officials at mar-a-lago see viewing the
boxes they had access to them that day
right there apparently later the
president came and met with them they
asked that a padlock be put on the
storage room where they were being held
that request was complied with and i've
had multiple people tell me that they
heard the president say you welcome back
anytime if you need to get any anything
in the in the storage feel free we'll
accommodate any request
so when you look at that timeline that
doesn't sound like somebody that's
trying to hide something does it
well that's the reason why from the very
beginning many of us said we need that
affidavit
because of this time period after that
june meeting if they were discussing a
lock on a door and
improving that security
the question is did they actually ask
for material to be moved to a secure
location at that time where they refused
what was the basis for their asking for
that added security
we don't know because we don't have that
affidavit what i can tell you is that
tssci material is highly uh classified
i've worked with it in the past when you
work with it you're not even allowed to
bring your phone into a skiff uh
security officers are very uh reluctant
to make any type of accommodation so if
they believed that there was tssci
material in june
it's rather bizarre that they would wait
this whole time before they made a move
of this kind
jonathan it's uh it's a mystery you're
right we'll learn a lot more with the
affidavit and uh a lot more in the days
to come appreciate you being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else